foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
but
hello hello let's welcome and open up
the doors so hello everybody who have
has joined us live here in our Zoom room
at
dailywood.zoom.com and hello to those
who are watching our live streams
out there in YouTube land and rumbleland
and Facebook hello and welcome welcome
my name is Becca Dukes I am the hostess
of this program and I am honored humbly
honored to be part of this Crusade where
we are bringing Dr Joel Wallach to you
Monday through Friday almost every day
we have a few days that we have to take
off because of other presentations that
are live in person off-site and away
from the office where we don't always
have good connections so we don't want
to schedule something and then have you
all show up and then we can't get on
because we don't have internet at the
remote locations that Dr Wallach and I
will be going to so Dr Wallach I'm super
excited to get you back on the road are
you excited
I'm always excited
well that doesn't sound excited at all
well yeah
is that excited
yeah
Mary
okay well folks we we are getting back
out and getting out there and being able
to help people where they're at because
not everybody has internet not everybody
um knows how to get on Zoom or for us
right here it's a little more difficult
when somebody wants to call in and ask
questions because unless I know that
they have a question I don't know to ask
them to unmute or to allow them to a
mute so I'm excited that we're going to
be doing this Dr Wallach in more formats
than just on YouTube but
I am very proud of all of our Watchers
and listeners Dr warlick because I see
when people share our program
and for those that of you that are
sharing
Kudos good job
that's what we're here for we're here to
spread a message of Hope a message that
allows us as individuals to not be
slaves to chemicals because what's the
difference between being dependent on a
prescribed narcotic to a nonline to to
an illegal narcotic Dr Wallach
well the only difference is there a
difference yeah the only difference is
the doctor writes prescription for one
he takes home some money so he can put
his kids through college
well it
talk about today Dr Wallach because I
know through all of your research and
folks if you don't know Dr Wallach Dr
Wallach has a degree in agriculture he
has a doctorate in veterinary medicine
he has three post doctorates in
pathology
and that's all before becoming a
naturopathic physician
and I know in some of your research Dr
Wallach you were looking at kidneys
and you aren't finding anything wrong
with the kidneys
yet whenever
they call it say kidney failure and I
know some of the cases that you worked
on it was said kidney failure but when
you look at the kidneys
what would have caused them to fail
well the kidneys are a series of tubes
and blood vessels and the other and it
has several functions now the kidneys
make urine
so it takes you know the toxic stuff on
the blood puts it into urine and you
have urination three four five times in
24 hours
and that's getting rid of this stuff
now also the kidneys
produce substances that make your blood
pressure go up why do you want your
blood pressure to go up because it wants
more blood going through itself so it
can filter it if it's not getting a
blood at once it sends out those
chemicals to make the blood pressure go
up
so when their blood pressure goes up it
tells you right away most of the time is
because your kidneys are having a
struggle
doing their job and so they're trying to
do their job by getting the blood
pressure to go up to force more blood
into the kidneys and of course then I
get people that haven't urinated
in 10 years
in 10 years okay those are kidneys are
so damaged their own dialysis six days a
week
and this is the sort of people that I
get that the doctors rub their hands and
say well
now we can try kidney transplant but we
haven't found anybody who's willing to
give us one of their kidneys we haven't
you know had somebody who's in a car
accident and died within you know
reasonable driving distance here that
had the same blood type and everything
like that and so we haven't really been
able to get you know most of these
people with kidney issues at the
transplant and so that's kind of where
the medical system is for kidneys well
really
um
I work on getting the kidneys working
again and we'll talk about that in a
minute
so that the blood pressure comes down
very quickly
because once it's working it doesn't
need to have how much pressure because
of having pressure was done by the
kidney to force more blood into into the
kidney okay
so we we are able to drop the blood
pressure into the normal ranges get them
off analysis
and they're happy as possible okay we do
this literally hundreds of times a month
all over the world
and we're here coming up here pretty
soon we're looking at
um 50 more
um countries joining us we're so excited
about this and then in another couple of
months after that another 20 will join
us since the 80 we have right now so
we're you know we're getting up there to
where we're like two-thirds of the
Nations being represented with
youngevity and kidneys
every
um keep invertebrate including human
beings you have kidneys we've got to
take care of them it's not hard okay and
it's not difficult but it's something
you have to be aware of what you need to
do you know everybody why I think about
my apartment okay think about my lungs I
got to take care of my liver but very
few people think what am I going to do
to take care of my kidneys that's
because doctors don't know
and so they don't I want a position to
give advice to the patient
so I want to point something out Dr
Wallach something that you said that
people don't
correlate
okay because I have seen so many people
with high blood pressure
and kidney problems
the high blood pressure is coming
because of the kidney problems am I
understanding this right right well the
kidney makes the blood pressure go up
trying to drive more blood in itself
okay so would that be a circulation
issue the Debbie dirty blood would that
be contamination what's what would be
causing them what happens is the kidney
contracts the arteries
okay in itself
when it's when things are going wrong
okay deficiencies and the pressure goes
out well once you get what what it wants
it opens up and the pressure and the
arteries comes down no more high blood
pressure
it's very simple I mean you can have
having pressure for 20 years and in two
weeks time we can get rid of it I mean
it's just that simple okay once you you
know
you have to
um
love your kidneys as you love your face
okay you really you really have to take
care of your kidneys and they will be
good to you for your entire life
so that they the vessels inside of them
contract meaning that they get tight and
small
which then restricts flow which
is blood pressure because the blood
pressure is trying to push the blood
through it so that the kidneys can
filter that's correct
so what are some things that would
negatively affect kidneys that are
either in our environment or in our diet
well bad food fried foods because of all
the inflammation caused by the oxidized
oils when you fried foods
and then you're talking about too much
sugar you're talking about
um oils also create inflammation okay
um and of course deficiencies of many
nutrients there's many nutrients and I
always hate to
um elaborate on a specific nutrient for
specific organs and things like that
because then people run to the grocery
store and they buy that one nutrient
they give some maybe a little benefit
for a while and then they die
because I used I used to do that Dr
Wallach and it never worked for me and
thankfully I did not die yeah and so
when they die of course game over but
they they have this thing I just want to
take the one that's going to help me
with my complaint
now you don't do that with your car okay
you don't put dirt from Texas in your
car and oh there's bound to be some oil
in it there's just dirt from Texas know
you put high quality oil in your car
okay and you put a high quality gasoline
in your car you put high quality
um brake fluid you put high quality
coolant you put high quality stuff for
your
transmission okay and you have to do the
same thing for yourself
and this is what I learned and
I learned this because uh my own
personal issues when I was nine years
old they're going to put me in one of
these high security hospitals I called
it a hospital prison
and because I was a very violent kid
they didn't have a name for what I had
but it was I could beat up you know at
nine years old at five years old I could
beat up a 200 pound man okay there's no
problem because I'm throwing bales of
hay and stuff like that on the farm and
so I was very strong
and
um my parents had taken me to 20
different doctors it was a combination
of
just simple medical doctors and private
practice
pediatricians psychiatrists pediatric
psychiatrists 20 of them over a
five-year period not one of them could
help me in any way shape or form not one
bit of help
and so I'm sitting on the end of my bed
on Friday night my parents are packing
my clothes because Monday we're going to
this
this hospital prison
and a prison hospital
it probably was more like a mental
institute because you were such an
aggressive uncontrollable the high
security was very high secure with armed
guards okay because if we're coming
after somebody one of the doctors they
just wanted to shoot you can get it over
with okay this was a very high security
facility
and um so I'm sitting on the end of my
bed and say okay why is night time my
parents are packing my clothes so we can
leave on Monday to go to this facility
Tim why am I having this struggle
you know I I'm not really a bad guy well
what's going on here
and then I started thinking you know
the animals on our farm they're drinking
the same water I am they're eating the
same grain you know the corn out of the
gardens I am and they don't have my
problems
and so Saturday morning I threw my
oatmeal
which caused you to not be able to
absorb nutrition because it has gluten
in it but you know I didn't know that
nobody knew that back then
and so I said okay and I threw my my
oatmeal and my Cheerios my Wheaties out
to the chickens I went to the barn I got
the Alfalfa pellets did we feed the cash
to but it wasn't for the Alfalfa Pals it
was for all the vitamins and minerals
that we had put in there okay we had the
manufacturing companies put these
vitamins and metals in the Alfalfa
pellets
and so Saturday morning I put them in my
cereal bowl put milk in it had them
Sunday morning did the same thing Monday
morning did the same thing
by three o'clock in the afternoon on
Monday I was cured
after two and a half days of just taking
all these vitamins and minerals okay and
all the drugs and all the doctors and
all their medical knowledge and stuff
couldn't help me
and it was very very dramatic but I
didn't say anything to anybody and my
parents kind of noticed it obviously and
so they didn't take me to the hospital
and said well you're doing pretty good
here let's just look at this for another
week or two okay and then you know after
a month or so people in school in a
church are all noticing and whispering
and pointing I mean there's a totally
different person
and after a while after about three
months they're coming to me saying I
have diabetes can you help me say oh my
gosh I'm only nine years old but I don't
know anything about diabetes and so I
had to look it up I looked it up in the
animal books that we had on the farm and
how did you know what violence meals
they gave for animals with all these
problems and I started recommending them
for people and I'm curing them I'm only
nine years old I'm curing them I'm
having pressure and diabetes arthritis
um
that kind of stuff and
the what should I say getting people off
of dialysis and all this kind of stuff
so I I really said okay I need to really
get on the academic piece of this and
that's when I graduated high school went
to the University of Missouri school of
Agriculture that's where I started
well let's
listen and something that you just
mentioned I had just pulled up an email
and this person that wrote this email
popped in and raised their hand that has
to do with how fast these supplements
work so
um real quick
Heather if you could give me a yes up
and down side to side can you share what
you wrote with and please
um
yes yes okay so I got the Tangy
Tangerine tablets and the first that
took one which was yesterday
uh it's me and my husband both took them
on our urine looked Radioactive
and I looked it up and it said something
about
maybe if you didn't need all the as much
as vitamins of some kind maybe then you
just pee it out
and uh
but today I mean I feel like a new
person and my husband told me this
morning he said you've got everything
has the office placebo effect on you
there ever was and I was like well maybe
it is maybe it's the vitamins I said I
guess we'll never know
I said but either way I feel like a new
person
very very good
and that's
okay yeah
and it's just the hangy tangerine
tablets did you have a diagnosis of all
your health problems
no I mean I'm 31 years old and
pretty healthy but
uh I don't know I felt miserable
yeah I mean I
I'm healthy but then going to get up out
of bed every morning and do anything and
I can't remember nothing and
are you from Texas or anything huh are
you from Texas
Eastern Kentucky okay I was gonna say
that's more Kentucky doc
yeah but he asked me the other day he
said I wonder why dogs don't get fat and
they don't want to lay around be lazy
all the time I said well
I said I just watched an episode on
beyond belief the other night but I
think it just answered that question and
it was that episode where you was on
there and talking about you know how
they have all the vitamins and minerals
and dog food but not baby formula
I had to see the FDA in federal court
eight times and I won all eight times uh
to force the manufacturers of baby
formulas Enfamil Similac and the like to
put the
um
um platinums and minerals in there and
of course we got rid of Cydia brosis
supposed to be a terrible birth defect
we got rid of mustard this way and I'm
just so proud that Jerry Lewis knew
about that before he died they put a gag
order on him so he couldn't say anything
to the public or the newspapers they got
rid of mimosis me got to send him a
death syndrome and sentimentation
doctors are saying that mothers were
laying on their babies and suffocating
them which is very simple sudden heart
death caused by nutritional deficiency
the same thing that comes with sudden
heart death and young athletes just when
it happened when they were six months
old or three months old they were
blaming it on the mothers laying on them
which wasn't true but the doctors
couldn't find anything they didn't know
what to look for and their Pathologists
didn't know what to look for
and so they weren't finding anything and
um I'm the one when I started looking
um we would uh Dr Milan and I we went to
China to uh Keyshawn
um university in hailing John Province
we did 1 700 autopsies and kids under
the age of 10. and the ones under one
year of age would have been diagnosed
with
um son of a dead syndrome in America
it was published in three languages
Mandarin Cantonese and English so nobody
can say I didn't do it okay
well doctor well like I have a question
and this is relation to kidneys and she
had just mentioned because the kidneys
are filtered that's why I'm asking this
question that's correct she just
mentioned how the urine was discolored
and you take a quality supplementation
it could in the beginning discolor your
urine what would be the cause of that is
that because I know having your urine be
clear just like clear water under the
tap and then your urine turns yellow or
orange well there's all kinds of
nutrients that cause those color changes
okay beta-carotene
um you know pre-vitamin a
um vitamin C can cause coloration of the
urine and so that's not a bad thing but
it just tells you that you're not
getting the maximum of any uh things
you're taking because you know you're
urinating some of it out
and so
um we have a program for this of course
we have the 90th Century which is our
basic program and then what we have is
What's called the
um ultimate daily plastic tablet so
three words ultimate daily classic Talos
that'll support healthy blood pressure
because it increases blood flow
everywhere including the brain and the
hearts and the liver and the kidneys and
now let's see here
um the dialysis
was it was the answer that the medical
system came up with where they put down
this machine and the machine takes the
place of your kidney cleaning the dirty
stuff out of your blood and making an
artificial urine okay that process is
called dialysis
and I get hundreds of people off of
dialysis every week all over the world
and we take people who are on dialysis
for 10 years six days a week and
urinated in 10 years
and you know in three days time they're
urinating okay so so you're saying that
basically the change of color of urine
is not a bad thing
but it could show that you're not
getting as much absorption as you could
potentially could yeah it's not a fatal
thing okay but it is something that says
kind of like a barometer or thermometer
is telling you that there's something
not 100 percent
okay
all right thank you so Heather if you
have an additional question go ahead and
stay with your hand up and I will get
back with you okay
okay my kids are getting off the bus so
I'll just have to check back in tomorrow
though
oh well we'll try to make it really
quick
so
um no let's go ahead and do it take it
right now go ahead Heather what is your
question for Dr Wallen
um
oh um the the vitamins just the says the
ones that I started taking is that like
all the 90 essential essential uh
nutrients I'll apologize I don't know
which one you're taking are you taking
so she got she has the Beyond tanky
Tangerine tablets so that's a good
portion of them but that's not the full
90. so that's not all I don't know it's
just part yes
what she needs is if finances are an
issue she needs the healthy
um
uh let's see body start pack yeah the
healthy starter pack
okay that'll give you the 90s and 60
Minutes 16 vitamins so I'm innocent
Three fatty acids if finances are not a
problem I'd go with the healthy brain
and heart pack that will give you 215
nutrients and you still have that core
90 in there okay and then of course you
got to remember uh to take
the um let's see here the ultimate daily
classic tablets take three of those
twice a day if you're on high blood
pressure medication don't cold turkey
off your medication but as the blood
pressure begins to come down you're
going to slowly reduce medication based
on the numbers okay
okay well I'll check back in tomorrow
and watch your all's video who's that
thank you for answering you know
yeah so Heather real quick real quick
you had mentioned that you've got brain
fog kind of sluggish what's in the brain
and heart pack is specifically designed
to give the body what it needs so that
you don't have to experience that each
and every day so if you can go with the
brain and heart pack you're getting
those additional essential fatty acids
which are a big part of supporting the
brain and its function
and the heart and the kidneys and the
lungs and the skin and hormone
development I mean it's just
everything's connected yeah and if
financing again Finance are not the
problem I would also throw in the I-26
which is a very very good for the white
matter of the brain the myelin which
makes up 25 of your brain weight and
spinal cord weight okay and so you want
to take three servings a day
it comes in powder in a canister like
this it comes in sticks
um no just one serving a day of that Doc
is plenty oh one serving okay
yeah you take it you take the chewables
which are three per day for one serving
so one serving and that helps the
digestive system also including that
brain gut connection yep
okay well I'll get on there and I'll
order some in the next little bit okay
all right all right thanks for joining
us today Heather
all right bye bye-bye bye-bye all right
well Dr wellick I'm glad we were able to
fit in kind of like a little testimony
of how fast she's feeling the results
and then helping her with the full 90
essential nutrients Plus what's needed
to help with some of the things that she
had going on and folks
that that's it you get the foundation
once you have the foundation if you've
got other things going on then we build
on that but you have to have that solid
foundation to keep things from
continuing to go backwards
because it's those nutrient deficiencies
that Dr Wallach found to be associated
with over 600 different poor health
conditions
so it's you've you've made it simple Dr
Wallach
well we try and of course that's why we
have so many books and um
the uh uh which I say is people learn
that these books are available and they
can buy them for wholesale
okay if I'm for wholesale and um it's
one of those things where uh the the
information in there
is stuff they don't teach them in
medical school these things are not
taught medical school all their taught
in medical Schoolhouse to quickly
relieve pain which is not a bad thing
as long as you're doing it at the same
time as you're repairing the tissues and
the organs
okay but just to just relieve the pain
and people continuously get worse and
worse and worse and so they're
increasing the amount of that drug or
maybe you're adding other drugs to it
and then they'll die in six months or a
year two or three years whereas if they
were taking all 90 essential nutrients
in Stand away from the bad stuff they
could live another 25 years
so when you're taking something to
control the pain and this was my story
there wasn't anything that was being
recommended by the medical field at all
to help support kidney function or liver
function but when you're taking those
chemicals Dr Wallach I've heard many
different
places that those chemicals will then
settle because they're being filtered
out is it the kidneys or the liver or
both
the liver is one of the biggest filters
systems in the body
okay the kidneys particularly filter
blood
but the liver filters everything okay
and it's one of those things where
the good nutrients are stored in the
liver the liver is a big storehouse
okay for so many different nutrients so
when you get a lot of it you're not
going to pee it out the liver says give
me the liver hangs on to it so when you
have a time of
um depletion or time of uh you're not
getting any more
deficiency is slowly releasing what you
need because the body say hey liver I
need some calcium hey liver I need some
of this I need some of that okay and so
um the good Lord put us together in a
very very interesting way
is when you think about it you're able
to store things you need every day so
when you have access you store it and so
when you're depleted you leave some seep
out to where you can utilize it and meet
your needs
I really think that's very cool
I think that is very cool and that works
very well with nutrients Dr Wallach but
what about the chemical Pharmaceuticals
I mean one starts wearing off and you're
instantly going for that bottle wanting
more because you're starting you're
getting that pain coming back and I'm
only speaking from experience
not an experience I ever want to
experience again so I stay on the 90
essential nutrients Plus
so it's not yeah plus you've seen you've
seen some of my pluses doc
yeah you take almost as much as I'd say
yeah almost almost I stay away from
those male hormone things though it's
not not my cup of tea
um but again going back to the chemicals
I mean it's storing there and
chemicals aren't feeding anything
in fact they have been shown to cause
damage yet they keep prescribing them
that is true mostly chemical
Pharmaceuticals have side effects
they're called
and negative side effects and some
people you know they get itching some
people uh they'll still urinate 20 times
a day yeah you know there's all kinds of
side effects
I just I know I get the side effects but
I just couldn't stand the pain anymore I
couldn't stand this symptom anymore so
I'm willing to put up with that stuff
the side effect of the drugs so I get
rid of the thing that I don't want and
and so that's what people had to deal
with
the body has a very unique way of
storing things
that um that aren't found uniformly
around the world minerals are not found
found uniformly around the world they're
found in veins like gold and silver
that's why there's some people like
hunza where people that would be 120 as
their life expectancy and then you have
people places like Kenya and East Africa
over the Olympic pictures is 59. okay
it's 120 more than 69 that's double
15. it's definitely double Dr Wallach
um but as I look back on some of the
things that I was on myself and the side
effects being cirrhosis of the liver and
kidney failure it's like why did I not
read those late those inserts
that came with my Pharmaceuticals then
and it's because folks were in so much
pain
we just want relief
well it covers up the pain and it
doesn't do anything
to address the underlying causes and
that's what this program is all about
bringing Dr Wallach to you is huge with
if you want any type of positive Health
journey and your journey
to getting old being
um more of not down in the dumps not a
bowl full of cherries with a bunch of
pits
we're talking being able to enjoy life
as you get older let me throw two famous
people in here if I may Pat Boone okay
and terrible arthritis I mean really
really bad arthritis is getting worse
and worse the doctors wanted to do a
double knee replacement on him and um we
got him on our healthy Bone and Joint
pack and got him on the
MSM and that kind of stuff and collagen
peptides vitamin D3
and we got rid of his arthritis he never
had to have any
joint Replacements and hip replacements
and knee Replacements all that kind of
stuff and he wrote the forward to this
book here the walk Revolution and then
Danny Glover had terrible
um let's see here he had
um
he had seizures Dr Wallach what
he had seizures yeah seizures and he had
epi
oh it's called epilepsy but seizures
epilepsy
epilepsy okay and those things and he
had it from a kid and it was getting
worse and worse and worse and he just
couldn't perform in his movies and songs
anymore and we got rid of that for him
and he wrote the last chapter in this
book The Walk Revolution Danny Glover
and of course we have the story
of
um
uh people like um
oh and Theo Ratliff great basketball
player and rebuild him it's a big story
so you know we'll do that we'll do that
another time but we rebuilt him he's in
this book oh that's the big story in
there and
um a lot of politicians and and famous
people and so forth including uh let's
see here
um
uh can't believe I said that
oh
um Steve here Jerry Lewis uh he didn't
have a problem but he was a guy you know
Jerry's Kids for most history we were
able to finally positive engine cure for
much history and he was so excited he
took it to the monsters Association in
September of 2011 so I think it was
September 4th 2011.
they fired him put a gag order on him so
he couldn't tell the stories to the
newspapers and you know TV and radio
stuff and the next day on the fifth they
shut down the Telethon the Telethon had
earned the most busy Association
2.6 billion dollars over 46 years they
shut it all down and fire Jerry Lewis
put a gag order on him he died a couple
years later but he knew that all his
work had not been in vain because he and
I together we found the closetration and
cure for emotions and he was just so so
so happy that he learned that before he
died
well and that's that's what this program
is all about Dr Wallach is to get that
story and Other Stories out that give
people hope yes the Wallach Revolution
you can get the Wallach Revolution it's
only been out for a month about just
over a month now you can go to
[Music]
drjwalik.com and order your copy today
that's
drjwalik.com look for a Wallach
Revolution
Dr Wallach Let's help some more people
because we have some hands up and we
have some questions out here in YouTube
land and Facebook and Rumble so let's go
ahead and get to them before we run out
of time okay first yeah we have going up
right now or the next one actually is
Carrie Kiri I know you were on video
just a few moments ago are you still
available
we can so naturopath to naturopath Dr
Wallach
she has some questions in regards to a
client and needs your guidance please
yes I have a um woman who was in a car
wreck in March and she got a concussion
and she has some serious lingering
um
symptoms that she's going to go to a
neurologist this week for so she's 57
she's five foot three weighs 155 the
accident was March 9th
um she has had and has always had
tinnitus
but she doesn't have any limb pain
radiating down it's mostly head and neck
pain but she's very nauseated and
um
uh has dizziness and Shop Right There
um did you ask her how many times at
night she wakes up to urinate once three
times five times ten times I did not ask
her that that should be a question you
ask everybody okay okay well she's got
osteoporosis of the skull that's the
tinnitus that's the squeezing of the
auditory branch of the age trailer by
the skull and she has this
um
um dizziness okay a balance issue
all right right all of this is found
the osteoporosis of the skull is found
in this book okay
all right and the top skull is normal
this is autopsy cut the top of the skull
off so then down on the brain can you
see it okay yeah okay and you see the
disk skull is only quarter of an inch
thick the bottom one is an autopsy we
cut the top of the skull off we're
looking down in the brain you can see
the skull is an inch and a half to two
inches thick because it has osteoporosis
that's not bone that's actually just
Scar Tissue because they have
osteoporosis and the squeezing the 12
pairs of cranial nursing squeezing the
spinal cord there's 37 different
diseases you can get
three of them or five of them or all of
them okay and doctors know nothing about
osteoporosis of the skull so this book
and CD set okay uh three authors myself
Dr Milan and the Rebecca here Rebecca
and I did the CD that goes along with it
and it's one of those things where
it makes you breathless the doctors know
nothing about this they'll send you to
their classmates so they can get you
know they'll treat you symptomatically
and you get some relief for the symptoms
but you really don't get down to the
basic root cause which is osteoporosis
this goal there's a very simple
nutritional deficiency and nothing about
this being a pathologist I would see
this at the autopsy table you know
they're dealing in the knees and this
stuff was going on
in the brain it was dealing in the
they're dealing
um in the kidneys okay because they're
urinating five times a night and it's
all in the brain okay being squeezed
okay the um
the spinal cord being squeezed and so
it's one of those things where okay this
can't go on this way because insurance
companies are just milking people for
doctors treating the wrong disease okay
and so that's why we came out with the
book in the CD and it's a big seller uh
it's written in the sixth grade reading
level so you don't have to be you know
have three three phds to understand
what's in there and it's very well
documented there's a lot of references
in the back if you want to go look at
some original research and that kind of
stuff
I read the e-version on a vacation but
uh I need to I need to buy the hardback
so that I can make notes
okay yeah but um
she says she does get up to go to the
bathroom she's I'm texting her uh she's
uh she's not saying how many times but
uh
recovery from the I mean she says right
now that all she wants to do is sleep
and go hide in a dark quiet room you
know she's become very noise sensitive
and nauseated and
it's been going on since March so is
there anything extra that we should do
because of the concussions no she needs
how much does she weigh
uh 145. 145 okay well she needs to get
rid of all the bad food she needs to
help written hard packs for months full
dose of everything twice a day cheese
two bottles a month to the MSM should
take three breakfast treat lunch dinner
time and I was going to rebuild and the
connective tissue or cartilage and
ligaments and tendons and her bone
matrix and all that kind of stuff right
then she needs the collagen peptides is
cool with other morning drinks for the
evening drink I wanted to have a rebound
so she gives energy from 100 nutrients
and the rebound I prefer the sticks and
the powder uh the the canisters or the
excuse me the cans you're gonna drink
the cans you got to pop the tops on them
the night before you're going to drink
them because I want to get rid of the
bubbly
and then I also
want her to take the ultimate daily
classic tablets
okay uh three of those twice a day is
two barrels a month and that'll get the
blood pressure down if she's on blood
pressure medication she cannot cold
turkey on the medication but as the
blood pressure drops you slowly reduce
the medication based on the numbers okay
all of those things are totally
reversible very quickly because there we
know that they're caused by osteoporosis
of the skull right
okay so do you think did the concussion
just aggravate the osteoporosis of the
skull did it just yeah maybe we have
osteoporosis of the legs you get whacked
in the legs it's going to hurt more
okay same thing to the skull if you have
uh if you have osteoporosis
um you don't have osteoporosis of one
bone right unless the approaches to my
trigger finger no you don't actually
approaches every bone in your body okay
you just have more awareness in your
trigger finger because your typing or
punching something on a machine or
something like that okay but um you
don't get that osteoposis in just one
bone or one region when you get
osteoporosis every bone and every joint
in your body is suffering
right okay so then this just aggravated
what was already there that's correct
okay
because I'm sure those complaints you
know about waking up at night three
times five times your night each kind of
thing she had this pain that pain and
when she got whacked uh you know in this
car wreck that that made the awareness
worse emphasized
yeah okay
all right keep us up to date you know
call us every couple of weeks let us
know her progress okay I will okay thank
you so much thank you
all right thank you Dr Kerry Dr Wallach
I have a question that came in last week
um in regards to
a 49 year old female
she's
165 pounds
she has had narcolepsy since she was 11.
epilepsy since she was 13.
a brain tumor surgery in 2015 and the
scar tissue is still causing seizures
no she does not wake up multiple times
to go to the bathroom at night
so and she said all of her
all of her issues are in her head so Dr
Wallach what would you recommend because
she doesn't have arthritis or any type
of joint and Bone issues
um she is on medications
I'm sorry
she's on medications she really
struggles with sleep and depression
um they keep adjusting her meds
and she binge eats
okay well when you binge eat that means
you're missing something okay
uh your body's telling you eat that's
called Pika p-i-c-a look it up and so
you can find in any dictionary pic and
that that's why people gain weight
that's why those 1200 pound humans
humans can get up to twelve hundred
fifteen hundred pounds uh when they're
eating 15 meals a day what are you doing
eating so many I don't know my my body's
just telling me I'm hungry I'm eating
okay that's because they're missing
nutrients
and so this is where hair analysis would
be very useful okay so to show them okay
what's going on here but I guarantee you
there's more going on than any doctor
would pick out from a standard medical
examination so I'll get a hair analysis
and get that book rare Earth's been
cures uh rare has been cures Amazon just
bought 100 of those this morning okay
it's 109. that was pretty awesome yeah
okay and so they need she needs to get
um one of those books um rare Earth's
been cures go to chapters 10 and 11 it
starts at page 272 it tells you how to
collect the hair how to package it where
to ship it don't forget to put in the
the check if you're in a foreign country
uh you had to use a money order uh any
state United States you can use your
personal check
and uh let's see here
in the meantime while we're waiting for
all that be sure that you're getting
that sample in so we know what's going
on do you have toxic mips there'll be
several charts in there the two charts
that I like one is the the essential
essential nutrients that tells you how
much of each one's in there
under here okay and then the second one
I like is the toxic Metals it tells you
how much lead and mercury and uranium
and stuff like that you have
and we know how to get rid of all that
also okay but this is we we have so many
people who go through this and they come
out the other end just really feeling 25
years younger and and getting rid of all
their symptoms and this and the other
because it's all due to
now either malnutrition or toxicity in
the brain and this is all
um resolvable but you have to know you
can't just guess you have to know what
you're treating
absolutely so Dr Wallach let's try to
get through at least three more hands
here in the next uh 10 minutes okay
Lauren go ahead and unmute yourself
hi everyone
um let me have my camera on I'm Lauren
I'm a new follower I heard you on um NPR
and yeah
um
I'm really having a tough time losing
weight I started birth control a couple
months ago and it seems just like the
whitest hit keeps growing I'm looking
into
some of the supplements and I take you
know collagen
on my own but
how much you weigh now
I'm 155. how tall are you
five two
okay so 110 would be about right for you
110 115 kind of thing yeah okay and so
um yeah any other issues any diabetes
have a pressure any joint pain
no I'm yeah I'm just getting M35 so I'm
starting to feel my knees so
okay wake up to go to the bathroom
probably twice a night now okay and what
about
um let's see here diabetes have a
pressure
no okay very good yeah you have
osteoporosis of the skull now babies are
born without she approaches clothes it's
not an age thing okay babies are born
with it they they
um
they get what's called Herb's palsy
they're paralyzed from the neck down
when they're born when they have
osteoporosis skeletal squeezing the
spinal cord okay
and doctors just think oh that's some
genetic disease you know I said mother
was deficient in these nutrients the
passage deficiencies onto the embryo
okay well here we go
uh and a hundred and fifty 155 pounds I
want you to get rid of all the bad foods
okay get my book the doctor always
cooking without the bad foods goes into
300 pages of safe recipes safe cooking
all that kind of stuff and it has a list
of the good food bad food list very
important
then you need to um
get two doses a day of the healthy brain
and heart pack take a full dose of
everything twice a day I get two vowels
a month of the MSM so you can take three
breakfast three lunch or dinner time
they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
vertebrae bone makes myself including
the knees and the hips and the shoulders
and back and skull and so forth and then
for the weight loss I want you to
replace one meal a day with what we call
our keto shake k-e-t-o shake now Rebecca
you can talk about this for a minute or
two on the keto Shake can you lose
weight was a keto shake for one meal a
day
um using the keto Shake by itself no but
when you put the 90 essential nutrients
in there absolutely the 90 essential
nutrients are it's the body that's
missing
and starving so it holds on to
everything
so you get on the full program and then
add that keto Shake which is full of
nutrition but without all the calories
so the body can focus on using the
nutrition instead of using its energy
to burn the calories
it makes it much easier
okay and so
um I think that's where we would go
and wouldn't hurt to get a hold of that
book it's all in your head the book and
the CD set to set and you'll understand
what's going on okay
there you go
it's all in your head and that that does
that causes the urination problem at
night because the skull is squeezing the
spinal cord and the spinal cord is
telling your urinary bladder to urinate
and that's why people say well why am I
here getting up three times a night to
take a pee
well that's because your skull is
squeezing the spinal cord and the spinal
cord is telling your urinary bladder to
urinate now it can't be the prostate
because this happens more frequently in
women than it does in men and women
don't have a prostate gland the last
time I looked okay
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
um and Lauren if you have any questions
feel free to get with your coach if you
don't have a coach that you're working
with then we can answer questions at
daily withdoc.com use that contact us
and just as a no for everybody if you
were
share this program by somebody specific
make sure that you get back with them
they took the time and they cared enough
to share this program with you because
they wanted you to get information that
is empowering to help you on your health
Journey so get back with them if there
is nobody to think then feel free to go
to our website daily with doc.com use
that contact us and one of our certified
holistic health coaches will get back to
you we also have a call team
855-949-3377 this is for those who are
not working with a health coach who have
never purchased any youngevity products
and are looking to make changes in their
life and be focused and directed towards
what's going to be the most beneficial
to them Dr Wallach we have a important
one coming up they're all important but
Marlene go ahead and unmute yourself
thank you so much for raising your hand
she has a question Dr Wallach
hi Doc and Becca thank you for uh this
opportunity to speak with the doc
um my husband was recently diagnosed
with gastric cancer he's 154 pounds
70 years old obviously male
and he's a diabetic so uh you know we
this is relatively new to us so we're
just trying to figure out the best way
to go about treating this nutritionally
okay what what did the doctors recommend
do they say we're going to take your
stomach out to they see we're going to
deal with chemotherapy do we know the
first thing they told us was you know
they'd have to remove the whole stomach
we weren't really down with that idea
but and then chemotherapy which is
supposed to start the week of the 21st
okay
all right 154 pounds well stomach cancer
is problematic because that's for all
your food you know needs to come in yeah
okay and so one of the things they can
start immediately is take our plant
minerals
our liquid plant minerals and rub a half
a teacup on his chest
three times a day and on his belly three
times a day on his back between his
shoulder blades and his lower back three
times a day on each of those so you're
gonna he could go through maybe three
quarts a month of the liquid plant
minerals okay we have seen miraculous
results because this supports the immune
system it's absorbed through the skin
almost like intravenous okay crazy how
fast it absorbs your skin okay good you
gotta lay down so it doesn't all roll
off into the wrong area okay you can't
stand up and put it on your chest it'll
just roll down your toes okay
you know lay down right yeah no problem
and then uh 154 pounds I also wanted to
have uh two healthy branded heart packs
per month the full dose of everything
twice a day if that's too much for the
stomach we do have
the um let's see here you know the kids
toddy which is a liquid okay it's a it's
kind of like a baby formula okay and so
this person 154 pounds will give you uh
on the back of the bottle
um how much to take uh per you know
pounds of body weight kind of thing and
then also uh he's gonna need to take the
efas to prevent blood clots and that
kind of stuff because we didn't put any
efas in there it has a lot of stuff and
of course those liquid plant minerals uh
on the skin of the chest and the belly
the upper back the lower back three
times a day and we're talking about half
a teacup in each location three times a
day okay okay but again when you put it
on there if they're laying down it won't
roll away it just goes right in the skin
like in a minute it just absorbs right
through the skin it's like intravenous
okay we've seen miracles happen with
that one okay and um
uh
let's start there and of course
um let's start there let's see here oh
we also have the rebound or sports drink
that has 100 nutrients in it you could
have what was that that uh rebound
rebound rebound okay
sorry about that
yeah
so Dr Wallach anything else did you get
the Z radical and the oxy body in there
because I know you have to get going yep
um
I think that's where I would start
because of the stomach issue okay
all right well yeah we'll get started
with that we'll get back to you with how
it goes and the kids toddy don't forget
the kids toddy got that got the kids
toddy the EFA the rebound and the plant
minerals that's correct let's start
there okay thank you can I if I could
add and I know Dr Wallach you need to
get going but thank you so much for
joining us here today we appreciate you
and if I could add to that um Marlene
just a note
on the rebound because you want to stay
clear of sugar when we're dealing with
with certain conditions that feed are
are be fed by Sugar the canister of the
rebound has the least amount of sugar so
we want to make sure that we
do that and then spread it out not like
three or four not like full doses all at
once if he needs that okay all right
thank you so much Becca thank you doc
all right thank you Marlene we
appreciate you coming on and glad that
we were able to get to raise your hand
earlier next time I know you were on an
hour early so I wanted to make sure we
got to you I love you thank you
yes yes love those time changes if I
could get my co-hosts on with me I could
not do this without them they are
absolutely vital and essential when it
comes to making a program work because
folks we're not in this by ourselves
we're in this as a team we all work
together as a community and we have a
lot of coaches who are on with us who
are part of that community and I know we
have guests that have been invited by
those coaches give back with your coach
as a community
we do great things
and if you are looking for a community
to be part of you are health-minded or
you want to be house-minded we have a
lot of amazing resources to help you do
that including the Institute of holistic
health that was co-founded by two of
youngevity's top leaders and Dr Wallach
they put together a certified holistic
health coach program that I'm very proud
to be a part of as a student services
director and each of the people that I
have
working with me almost everyone that is
part of our team our call team our
just our community they are so eager to
jump in and be part of this certified
holistic health coach course and the
information that they learn from it
we have doctors like Carrie who was just
on with us who just loved the course I
have doctors like Dr Debbie who have
gone through the course she's a retired
oncology surgeon folks and she's just
amazed at the information that she's
learned through this program that she
has now been able to implement in her
private practice through alternative
medicine
we've got myself I'm not a doctor yes I
was herbalist did a lot with herbs and
tried to do nutrition but I couldn't fix
myself till I found youngevity and
that's what gave me my life back and I
know each of my co-hosts have a similar
story
give us 90 days
learn about what you yourself can do
as an individual when it comes to the
body there's four main areas of Health
folks if you've got deficiencies
all four areas are affected and that's
what this coaching course offers and
teaches
and then gives us Solutions let's not
just tell you everything that's wrong
but we go into Solutions as well so get
back with the person that shared this
program with you ask them if they know
anything about the health coach program
if they don't you can go to
coach with Becca and I have information
about the program there
this program
is just touching lives around the world
I know we didn't get to all the hands
that were up or all the questions out on
YouTube please please please
go to dailywooddoc.com use that contact
us and send us your questions I am going
through the ones that we already have Dr
wallach's protocols for we're getting
those protocols to those that have
answered the requests have been great
it's just overwhelming how many people
are finally looking for alternative
options because what they're doing is no
longer working
my name is Becca Dukes the hostess of
this program I have on with me Rosella
Sanchez who does a lot of my technical
stuff for me to make sure everything is
loading and so I don't have to stress
about that she gets to stress over that
so thank you sister
um we have sherry Browning who is going
through and letting people in and
watching cameras and watching the chat
we have Marilyn who's doing just an
absolutely fabulous job as Dr Wallach as
giving these recommendations she is then
transcribing them and putting them into
the chat so if you're here live with us
I hope you had that chat on because then
you would have been able to see that
information if you are out on our
streams we invite you to come join us
sometime in our live Zoom daily with Doc
zoom.com is the easiest way to get there
but also go to our website daily with
doc.com And subscribe to our newsletter
we have an amazing newsletter that we're
putting together but right now
each week we are sending you links to
the previous week's programming
it also sends your the direct
information on how to get on with us
here on daily with Doc so there's a lot
of things that you can do on your own to
help yourself
you don't have to have somebody to tell
you what it is or a white piece of paper
to take to a pharmacy folks
nutrition your body's starving for it
it's not starving for pharmaceuticals
until next time
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you